salve a tutti con una sera vi state
chiedendo cosa ci fa un hacker
in questo contesto quindi oltre a minare
la credibilità della sapienza diciamo
quindi ecco gli organizzatori e oltre
siamo vengo qui a pieno titolo come
mangione quindi è secondo è proprio
quello che mi dicevo c'è quello di venir
fuori da un background quello della
cultura cyberpunk una cultura che si
ispirava a questi esperimenti di riposi
scienziati che negli anni sessanta
cominciavano ad ipotizzare la vita
dell'uomo su altri pianeti e inventando
appunto questo ente cyborg dove i
confini tra vuole macchina erano sfumati
una suggestione scientifica che ha
impressionato non filoni scientifici ma
anche di fantascienza di letteratura un
film da cui noi siamo ispirati e
l'abbiamo avuto la fortuna per caso non
poco come tutte le storie di di questa
sera ma un po con i casi della vita di
sperimentare la rete quindi ricordo per
caso quando c'era questo mio vicino di
casa con cui giocavamo smontavamo gli
sterili amplificatori eccetera arrivo
dopo un viaggio in america con un costo
di una specie di citofono disse guarda
questo è un modem che cos'è allora c'è
la suo cugino che l'aveva in questa
università americana col numero di
telefono
c'erano i telefoni quelli a bachelite ve
li ricordate quindi si poggiavano per la
cornetta su e cominciamo a fare questi
numeri ci colleghiamo questa finestra
questo internet una cosa bellissima
tutto molto diverso da come da come oggi
cominciamo a fare esercizio di rete
sostanzialmente pensate erano tempi dove
non esiste o appunto di internet diffuso
e neanche i telefoni erotici quindi mio
padre non si spiegava queste bollette di
un milione due milioni 3 che ogni due
mesi
noi ci impegniamo a lavorare per pagarci
no questo questo accesso a questa rete
una rete che per noi è stata sempre
qualcosa di sociale e che appunto vedeva
in questa possibilità
una possibilità
non tanto più lontana da quello che
succede oggi perché se ci pensate
oggi siamo tutti i cyborg e con il
nostro smartphone per la prima volta
abbiamo un'estensione totale dei nostri
sensi possiamo determinare la nostra
posizione dello spazio estendere la
nostra vista il nostro udito è la cosa
più importante creare ricevere e
processare contenuti al pari di ogni
altro media quindi definendo noi stessi
appunto come un in ford come un hub che
distribuisce contenuti
in realtà questo cosa ha fatto emergere
fatto emergere quello che da millenni
tutte le sacre scritture di ogni
tradizione spirituale ci dicono è che
noi abbiamo bisogno di vederlo
altrimenti non ci credevamo cioè il
fatto che siamo tutti connessi e questa
interconnessione tra di noi oggi
misurabile verificabile quindi mappa b
non ci dava la possibilità anche di
capire i nodi di influenza come
aggregazioni semantiche ha creato questo
livello superiore che avvolge il mondo
almeno parte del mondo che si chiama
appunto definito info sfera dal filosofo
luciano floridi in questa in questo
livello di info spera ci ha portato a un
certo punto a fare delle riflessioni di
natura diversa da quelle tipiche dei
media oggi chiamiamo tutto questo ancora
social media spesso è questo il termine
che lo usiamo per comunità perché è
servito a stracciare alcune categorie
dei mezzi di comunicazione per vendere
pubblicità sostanzialmente e anche forse
per una certa pigrizia degli studiosi
che fino a un certo punto hanno portato
avanti dissidenti media studies non
applicando via questo contesto
pensate che facebook alla fine sarà pure
innovativo ma il modello è ancora un
quadratino con la pubblicità c'è lo
stesso dirigente e
il messaggero benché preferenziale e che
voglio dire con tutte le novità del caso
e quindi invece ci era sembrato giusto
un certo punto introdurre questa materia
diversa che mettono grafia digitale
proprio perché avevo capito che tutto
questo non è un mezzo di comunicazione
ma un ecosistema ha dato dalle
piattaforme tecnologiche youtube
facebook twitter e quelle che saranno ma
soprattutto dall interazione delle
persone di chi vive in questi ecosistemi
che continuamente poi ci rimbalzano da
una dimensione mediatica è una reale e
quindi abbiamo inventato queste
fotografie digitale cadendo studiando le
mutazioni anche antropologiche che la
questa estensione quindi questo livello
dell'info sfera determinavano
determinavano tra quelli che sono i
nativi digitali ma anche quelli che sono
pratici di questo ecosistema
ed è interessante perché abbiamo visto
che tutto al di là del diciamo di quello
che avviene nel in maniera contingente i
pubblici stanno operando delle di
semantizzazione radicali delle categorie
di base come lo spazio e il tempo
pensate noi siamo abituati quindi a
vivere non una dimensione locale a
percepire la comunità e gli spazi come
gli spazi fisici questi a roma il
pantheon
ma forse dovremmo iniziare a considerare
la dimensione non solo locale ma anche
quella iperlocale quindi non solo il
luogo ma anche il luogo che è dato da
tutte le informazioni che i vari infor
di noi noi cyborg continuamente
processiamo dal luogo nelle nostre reti
delle nostre di sociale le
interconnessioni che possiamo mettere in
opera ma anche tutto quello che con roma
ci pensate tutte le informazioni anche
degli spazi vuoi dire tutti i livelli
aumentati di informazioni che possiamo
trovare nei monumenti nei ristoranti e
banalmente anche le sedi delle
recensioni su tripadvisor in qualche
modo riscrivono l'ontologia del posto
perché un oggetto del reale più tutte le
informazioni che noi aggiungiamo quindi
sostanzialmente i giochi cambiano e
cambiano in maniera ancora più radicale
se pensiamo che ogni luogo appunto è un
iper luogo in senso totale ovvero è una
narrazione c'è roma e oggi soprattutto
una narrativa che sfugge e non
appartiene certamente soltanto a chi
sulla carta di credito già scritto roma
come posto di nascita luogo dove vivere
e quindi sostanzialmente la necessità di
intercettare questi flussi narrativi
vede sono persone no quindi che vivono e
decidono di vivere di partecipare alla
creazione di senso interesse intorno a
questa narrazione ma vi dirò che la cosa
più interessante avviene sul fronte del
del tempo
lei ci ha abituati siamo stati abituati
a pensare il tempo come qualcosa nodi
isolabile che scorre fuori da noi
abbiamo pensato un futuro fatto di
modernità e stato questo mito della
tecnologia noi ci ha portato a fare una
corsa all'ultimo hype l'ultimo gadget
del momento sembrerebbe che dobbiamo
essere sempre alla rincorsa di qualcosa
che fuori da noi quindi questo è il
tempo della modernità al tempo del
mercato che si fermano un'unica
dimensione quella cronologica ma se ci
pensate bene
metaforicamente questo è il broadcast
qualcosa di poco innovativo questo è il
tempo della tv a letto dopo carosello il
telegiornale di pranzo oggi il tempo di
oggi più vicino a youtube le persone
vogliono scegliere
abbiamo delle piattaforme dove possiamo
vedere l'ultimo videoclip dei chemical
brothers ma anche alla puntata di happy
days vogliono e quindi andando a
recuperare il secondo nome del tempo che
da queste parti della cultura
mediterranea è il kairos il tempo di dio
nel tempo come scelta
e stiamo vedendo che è appunto questa
possibilità di ragionare per livelli
quanti ci offre ai giovani oggi a chi
voglia fare innovazione soprattutto
l'innovazione di scegliersi che tipo di
innovazione coltivare quale tipo di
futuro cioè diventa sempre più un atto
politico la capacità di mettere insieme
elementi del passato che magari nella
corsa verso quella modernità abbiamo
perso e che sono utili per la nostra
sopravvivenza
può essere che la tecnologia ci sia
suggerendo delle vie per uscire fuori
dal fallimento del presente attraverso
la possibilità di combinare pezzi del
passato con elementi del presente per
scegliere qual è il futuro che vogliamo
vivere e in questa ottica
inutile dirvi che su questo piano si sta
giocando la partita nell'individuazione
di nuovi progetti di sviluppo nuove vie
di sviluppo e quindi tutta l'etica delle
start up no quindi del tutto questo
marasma che mi devo dirvi
dal mio punto di vista mi sembra molto
vicino alla cec pop economy
se pensate la narrazione dei giornali
quale c'è un ragazzo brillantone fa una
simpatica
se la compra un bel ci fa un pacco di
soldi va al hawa e vi saluta e tutti
quanti gli altri mi sento questo modello
di sviluppo a parte che poi glieli danno
ovviamente i soldi per delle hawaii non
è così c'è tutta questa intelligenza
collettiva questo general intellect
veramente deve servire per fare un'altra
per geolocalizzare le cacche dei cani
questo è dove siamo arrivati dove
possiamo dove ci ha portato questa
questa innovazione
a un certo punto vi dirò sentendo la
paura di essere anche complice di questa
di questa cosa come mi diceva una
presentazione mi sono occupato di
innovazione a più livelli
ho cercato con il gruppo di ricerca di
due a lab di capire se ci fosse una via
italiana alla social innovation
mediterranea e abbiamo quindi così come
ci suggerisce la venografia cercato
quali fossero quegli innovatori che
appunto rispondevano a quella che a
detta al triple bottom line cioè che
portassero avanti innovazioni
economicamente socialmente ed
ambientalmente sostenibili c'è significa
dei progetti anche di business cioè
progetti anche che autosostenibili
sostenibili dalla dimensione del mercato
che però nel frattempo risolvono
problemi delle comunità
la risposta non è stata banale perché
abbiamo intercettato un flusso sempre
più ampio di downshifting che vede
persone strass filati che hanno studiato
all'estero che hanno fatto magari anche
professioni della finanza nel marketing
digitale avanzato che sempre di più
stanno ritornando ad applicarsi diciamo
dei loro delle loro terreni terreni e di
vivere in modo diverso la la campagna e
l'agricoltura e sono tanti tornano
facendo portando dentro alla cultura
tecnologica la capacità di essere
nell'info sfera portano la possibilità
di fare network la cultura della
condivisione portano strumenti tipici
appunto di altre aree di innovazione e
li portano appunto all'interno di un
framework quindi non più
il provinciale quindi cosa succede
l'info sfera azzera la distanza tra una
modernità metropolitana dove avvengono
le cose del futuro e una ruralità
perennemente ancorato al passato e fa sì
che queste scelte no di questi di questi
giovani quindi attraverso un vissuto non
più provinciale quindi da sempre quella
gente quando si adotta le palle di stare
in città se n'è andato in campagna
parola non scelte di negazione scelte
private
oggi attraverso la dimensione delle info
sfera sono scelte politiche già solo il
fatto di fare un self di giocare con
arduino risolvere un problema e postarlo
su un blog fare l'impianto di
applicazione eccetera immette
all'interno di questo livello dell'info
spera una visione altra di sviluppo
una visione che ci suggerisce una bella
via d'uscita perché noi ad oggi
e questa la dimensione che viviamo noi
diamo la dimensione dove tutte le storie
di grandi agricoltura di recupero della
tipicità sono storie di sofferenza sole
di guerra si diceva prima perché sono
storie dove non conviene oggi coltivare
prodotti di qualità perché perché il
valore
il prodotto ormai è solo un escamotage
per mettere in atto altri livelli di di
valorizzazione valorizzazione che
avviene nella logistica avviene sul
piano del branding no pensate il
branding sono tutte le palle del
marketing che vi dice per vendere un
prodotto di scarsa qualità per
aumentarne il valore
per non parlare della dimensione della
finanza cioè i supermercati non hanno
interesse di vendere di carote yogurt
dentifricio il supermercato guadagna sul
fatto che voi pagate in contanti
quello che loro pagano a 360 giorni
magari strozzando anche i produttori
tutto questo è nelle mani di pochissime
realtà che non sono certamente realtà
locale se vedete qui sono tutte le
referenze no del dei prodotti che
troviamo nei supermercati sono ve ne
sono ben poche multinazionali che
gestiscono tutto questo è la maggior
parte di loro è in svizzera
certamente non
non sono qui a roma o altrove
la cosa interessante quella che quel
modello proposto dalle storie dei
giovani che stanno ritornando quindi
questi contadini un 3.0 quindi questa
dimensione di di smart plurality
innanzitutto rompe quella gerarchia e
quindi mette al centro la tecnologia è
tutto il massimo dell'innovazione non
per andare ancora incontro al chimico
alla massimizzazione la massimizzazione
del profitto ma per lavorare di tornare
a mettere al centro produzioni di
qualità e già questo come dicevo rompe
quella gerarchia ma la cosa più
interessante è che oltre a rimettere al
centro il prodotto attraverso punto gli
strumenti dell'innovazione si operano
delle ri semantizzazione importanti di
queste tre aree infatti vediamo che al
posto della logistica
c'è sempre più forte la dimensione della
disintermediazione cioè più facile
sempre azzerare i livelli medi tra chi
produce e chi consuma e questo significa
che attraverso facebook possa avere una
fattoria didattica fanno venire le
persone o tutti i farmer market come
vedete che si organizzano nelle città ma
anche tutte le app cortile a zolle che
consentono di portarvi a casa prodotti
di qualità a un prezzo abbordabile
pagando meglio chi produce al posto del
branding wind e al posto di quelle sono
dette appunto tutte le palle del
marketing
lo dico perché è il titolo di un libro
celebre abbiamo uno storytelling
autentico abbiamo il territorio la
matrice antropologica dei prodotti che
la storia del prodotto che parla di per
sé e la cosa interessante si crei un
meccanismo osmotico dove il prodotto
parla del territorio e quando parla del
territorio parlo del prodotto non
pensate al chianti per non parlare di
tutte le altre tipicità biodiversità
d'italia e quindi un meccanismo virtuoso
dove la comunità vedete è sempre
presente non è presente solo alla fine
non è il target a cui vendere qualcosa
qui
stiamo andando incontro appunto a
processi di demercificazione del cibo
quindi dove il cibo diventa un bene
comune non soltanto una merce e la cosa
più importante che tutti questi
meccanismi piuttosto che prendere
capitali e portarli lì in svizzera dove
ha fatto vedere quell'altra flight opera
continuamente meccanismi di
redistribuzione del valore delle
comunità e non è banale e quindi questo
sostanzialmente ci suggerisce un modello
di sviluppo diciamo più praticabili
quindi più vicino a quelle che sono le
necessità dell'italia quindi un modello
di sviluppo che come direbbe un nostro
grande maestro che franco cassano è una
frase che apre al abd el nella nostra
sede c'è scritto questo scritto che
bisogna ritornare a riguardare ai nostri
luoghi
nel senso di averne riguardo di curare i
nostri luoghi nostre comunità e nel
senso anche di di guardarli con occhi
innovativi occhi nuovi per scoprire che
sono un giacimento una miniera d'oro sul
quale possiamo costruire un modello di
sviluppo che per la prima volta non ci
vede sudditi ma si può vedere
protagonisti grazie mille